well I'm Molly come on - liable to catch
on how are you guys doing what are the
questions that are usually asked when
people start practicing is that okay now
I'm practicing but what group should I
follow what sexual I follow woman is
Sonia slam because all of these there's
so many groups there's so many different
whatever like I'm confused so awful
monster someone has an answer for that
in the long hadith which is narrated by
how they form any event I'm gonna give
you the bottom line the Prophet was
advising her deaf opinion man I have to
keep away from bad things I had to keep
away from people or dohat yet take a
lemon and we all seen it in it and they
speak with our speech but actually who
died
I like web agenda that they're gonna be
door at the dour carriers that are gonna
be calling two hell's gates basically
and he said he says he said basically to
stick with the community of Muslims and
their chief stick with a community of
Muslims and not in Memphis he said this
is very clever how they if I said what
what if there is no community like
cohesive community and there is no II
Men there's not mmm there's no leader
so before back in the days obviously we
had a unified like Islamic governance
and you had a and leader but now that's
not okay so this applies to us so the
pros have said fat as in till kill
filipok Allah he says leave all of those
groups alone even if you have to buy at
the base of a tree leave all of those
groups alone there's a very powerful
important the prophets also their force
don't become intersects why do we call
us off suddenly it just means when we
say suddenly by the way we're just
differentiating ourselves from the Shia
who don't believe in certain things that
we believe like for example the the
model or the the just nature that nature
of the Sahaba
of the Companions so when we say Sunni
we just mean sooner Tanabe or the the
way of the Prophet would you master
Sahaba or the community of the Sahaba
for example right a loose wenatchee well
Jamaa that's what we mean it's not it's
not actually mention the Quran like the
word Sunni in that sense yeah but that's
what we mean by so we differentiate
ourselves from those Shia
we have certain different beliefs when
it comes to Imam and the Sahaba right
but the Prophet is saying apart from
this apart apart from the fact that okay
because another hadith says you know man
Ali he was hobby what I'm fond of might
my friends are upon and stuff like that
but apart from that don't go into sects
don't go to sub-sectors don't become
tribal within this it's time came to
abolish that kind of sectarianism okay
so that's your answer your answer is
don't become sectarian what is the
biggest threat to this kind of notion of
non-sectarian is another professor
Salaam clearly made clear basically in
his speech in is the hadith the biggest
threat to it are certain projects within
Islam which are designated almost to
create sectarian rift there are
different ones and I don't have the time
here to go into every different strand
sub strand etc but I want to give you
just one example today of a particular
two projects yeah within Islam which are
causing a lot of havoc that you need to
know about they're causing disturbance
disruption and they're causing all kinds
of problems and they need to be treated
okay they are cancerous so they need to
be acknowledged and dealt with the two
products in question for me I'm talking
about here that experie project and the
tab di project before I before I get to
this and tell you what those two
projects are and why they are so
dangerous for the Muslims I want to
mention one thing there was a study that
was conducted by a king which is an
institute in America which does great
work and it was a sociological study
which was methodologically robust it was
one which investigated doubt I'll leave
the description leave a link to the
description and it asked participants I
think it was more than 600 of them what
causes most doubts for them and they put
so many things in the list they put
things like atheist arguments women's
rights and so on and so forth at the top
of the list was basically what you would
call religious dogmatism or that there's
only one way to practice religion which
falls right into
notions of sectarianism because if you
say there's only one way to practice
then you're basically you have to be
dogmatic to make that stay I'm not
talking about the US all of the religion
or things you have to be in order to
become Muslim and to be practicing as a
Muslim like believing in five pillars of
Islam and all these things I'm talking
about the mind you shake the photo are
if you like yeah
so these that's an important thing and
this the reason why I'm bringing this to
your attention that study to your
attention is to show you to the extent
to which it should be our remit to deal
with these individuals yeah because if
if our remit is okay we're trying to
keep people solid within their faith and
bring people within Islam so you can
call it an evangelizing remit or an
educative Rhema as well as if you want
to call it that and apologetic remit
yeah to rationalize it to Muslims that
we're afraid that we'll get down and
then slippery slope down to apostasy
then if this is at the top of the list
of things that they find doubtful about
the religion and we can't ignore it okay
okay so having said that if it's part of
the remit now we need to deal with the
tech theories and the tap the ice people
are the tech field is we know they are
texting these are people who
excommunicate people from the religion
on its lap and they do so on non
normative grounds so for example of
someone who believes in the essential or
soul of the Islamic faith and they don't
add to it that which will disturb the
the order or the Ajmer the consensus
then they would still find some loophole
to excommunicate them and in addition to
the excommunication they'll do something
called to serve so tech theaters are
slowly which is though it's a chain
takfeer a chain type of excommunication
which has put scarifications the most
severe which is what we're seeing with
Isis is what we're seeing with al-qaeda
and these groups who fight who actually
find
jurisprudential justification to kill
innocent bystander people in their
monstrous acts that they've been doing
mostly to Muslims
may be added but as well to non-muslims
in the in these countries as well so us
not dealing with those for example will
give us trouble the extent of which has
been witnessed in let's say for example
the previous time or in the last 20
years for example especially after 9/11
etc so these individuals their ideas and
their justifications have been and
continue to be refuted on an
intellectual level we can't be thinking
that this is that's it it's dead now
they don't want to come back because all
it takes is a certain set of situations
political situations yeah and that idea
will become more attractive to people
once again so that's one set one project
of individuals that we need to deal with
yeah some dogs barking out there but you
know what it's funny that the dogs are
barking because I'm gonna be speaking
about some people are being barking and
that's the second group which is the TI
project now that FDI project may not be
and I'll be very clear they're not as
dramatically dangerous obviously they're
not at all from a physical perspective
political perspective anything like the
sick fear ease however the tip the eyes
people like those who claim to follow
Robert Holley the s pubs and so on those
individuals have the object a stated
objective of classifying Muslims Sunni
Muslims who follow Sunnah normative
Islam as deviants and and so on and so
misguided and they do so looking at some
of their alleged mistakes
mostly misrepresented maligning them and
classifying them as innovators and so on
so famously they tried to do so with
people like Mufti Menken Zakir Naik and
normally Hanh and those individuals they
don't have an approach of K the Imam
said some things which are correct here
and some things which are not good Kulu
ins as Malik says Kulu insulin you are
woman who I ordered wale that everybody
you take from them and you we have to
you have to really refute them on
certain issues unless I have heard of
combat except for the person who resides
in this harbor or grave which is the
Prophet he was pointing at the problem
house are Salam
then I have the attitude of nuance okay
let's see where he's right in Wesley way
is wrong intellectual criticism and in
an academic sense they don't have that
they'll write you off and they're very
dogmatic the reason why these
individuals in to be warned again
against is because like the tech fear is
they are dour
traitors they are dour traitors because
if someone is spending twenty years
doing dour someone like zakir naik or
someone like bilal philips yeah well
someone like multi make so many is doing
that i don't know how many years he's
been doing that one has had such a
positive impact on the muslim community
and then you come along and say he's
written off he's nothing yeah he's it's
not like that he's he's got some
goodness or there's no there's nothing
there it's just like he's palace you
can't listen to him he's written off I'm
sorry he's not even suddenly whatever if
you're gonna say that and you're gonna
be very confident about saying that then
I say to you that you probably have
something in your heart that you need to
check and jealousy is a dangerous game
especially if you play it with those
diet over there that's my that's my
that's what I'll say to you jealous is a
dangerous game especially if you play
with the diet over there who have done
more then you can ever do
someone like Mufti man cuz you know
seriously I hope you can never do what
he done and you know that it's
impossible you've reached your boiling
point I haven't said that now those
individuals recently got caught
red-handed and it was such a devastating
embarrassment for them that they're
scurrying in desperation because I made
it as part of my project like I do with
everything else I I spent some time with
the Atheist spend some time with the
Christian apologists I spent some time
with the Jews and Zionists whatever and
I spent some time with you guys as well
cuz you're dangerous too they are
traitors sit down you're dangerous
didn't our you'll right and everyone off
you're attacking everybody who have you
spared except for your mache you've
spare you have spared very limited
amount of people in there and OMA you're
writing about everyone
and you sales RP their mistake and so on
you guys are dogmatic and your dog man
leads to apostasy and doubt let me give
you one example one of their figureheads
called ever I out the other day I just
saw in his website now he was saying
that he believes in the geocentric model
he's gonna he's actually gonna produce a
book that's 150 page long arguing on
scientific grounds why geocentrism geo
centricity is correct and Helius
interest is false
now if if you don't know the basics
yeah of how much that is a waste of your
time that is a waste of your time you're
not gonna undo the scientific Copernican
revolution my friend yeah don't think
you're gonna you might have delusions of
grandeur but you're not gonna do that
but you need to add to this that this
dogma that you're believing in here it's
actually gonna lead to apostasy because
someone's gonna say well I don't believe
in Geo centricity I actually believe in
the way of evidence from the scientific
community okay
what's more than that there's no Popeye
verse in the Quran that says what you're
trying to say by the admission of the
scholars you follow
for example even as I mean he said it's
not cutting in one of his Shero hand and
no way as for you had these and as Benny
who you take from I don't bandy who you
take from he believed in the earth was
moving you say you believe in a
stationary F so what you're saying is
Kufa to believe in Helio centricity well
Allen body doesn't believe in what you
believe in he believes that the office
bra is is orbiting and spinning and so
on funkiness energy Donnie love little
huggy for a leadership coffee and I mean
the world of hockey find me and I
thought when we didn't dr. Lenny Nate
and nation and know if it's in Sherlock
or woman was Veronica so son and it had
that I'm any fella with the wife and
when the Mohave satphone yahoo Mirko de
la Salsa dam and the Muslims Asahi in
hadith Ana's American law I know the
history tab you know he know my father
Dehon in the my oven oven on 200
yamato-kun be a minimally near Pancho
Villa was a bottom mama I want to
communicate more in the air content to
Allah moratorium panel Cabrera Lisa V no
no food 800 euros per night Sarah when
Heather who are a hadith e o manasa
agent military he in the manly believer
only a of Muhammad Ali when Derek
nestled in Nepal and now language repeat
alguna vez una nanofy having a people at
me in volume the qualities upon me and
an ultra wheel and not a guru positively
hydrogen he had a revolver see when you
kill Aslam and Merida you shall in Lamia
Nicole - OH
other and artificial fur shall come up
with - Omar and her crew have he had a
la cama Polynesian vocaroo - aqui esta
Hoon na CMR is a stock burner and
popular had a media he we love it - a
cool here Tommy a little walk a bit for
that because he doesn't see it the way
you're seen it and I'll put the
description and the I'll put the link in
the kitchen input the same for ya so I'm
trying to get out is that this dogma
that these guys believe in they they're
forcing you to believe in ridiculous
propositions
yeah which is a proposition which says
you have to believe in geo centricity
otherwise you're doing cook
and believe me that's causing grave
doubt within their little community
causing apostasy causing doubts and
you're saying we shouldn't you shouldn't
just ignore them no we need to have a
group of people that dealing with these
individuals on their own on a yearly
basis just like we need to have a group
of people that deal with tech fillies
because if we don't have a group of
people dealing with its affiliates then
they're gonna do their head and their
deconstruction for a very long time for
20 years four years no one's gonna reply
to them and they're gonna grow because
they're gonna feel like themselves
irrefutable because no one's dealing
with them and then you're gonna have
so-called Islamic state doing monstrous
acts and killing people in the name of
religion and do we take responsibility
for that we should take some
responsibility for that
obviously we'll attach it away 0 to 0 we
know the Koran says with one soul is not
held to account for what i never saw
does but if we're not doing anything
about the muslim community then we
shouldn't just wait and see what's gonna
happen or let's just see this group
continually calling us innovators
continue this group calling us careful
know there needs to be some kind of
effort there is to be some kind of group
on social media yeah that I'll focus on
this the good news is actually came
across a great website or great YouTube
channel called SP files and this YouTube
channel is dealing directly from what it
seems to be the case I haven't reviewed
all the content but it seems to me like
they're doing this we're jib that we
have to do this fast cafe that someone
has to come yeah oh yeah come B which is
exposing these individuals exposing them
for their double standards and the fact
that they don't themselves have what
they say they have which is knowledge
they don't they're not they're not
qualified they're not scholars and
they're they're all one of them we've
already exposed in last year's name was
Abu ha deja who cannot recite the Quran
by his doing tip the anti-lock palek
didn't have D on the people listen to
how he recites the Quran sayin well yeah
and while you were a lovely one well
yeah tomorrow
siren siren kathira as a large and owada
has taken well occurred Menelik admin
Allahu Alem opening it up is by a fee
him Rosalyn Menon [__] him he has to do
I lay him aya t he were used up key him
were you a limo Maliki table while
hikmah were in car Newman ugly min Kabul
oh la fille de la Lima Bean Katya come
min allahi noon what kita boom ooh bean
yes didi he'll be allahu min minute saba
rid the world ridwana who Subaru salawa
you creature whom min Abdullah Marty
Eleanor people like him and Halima have
one thing in common
abouhalima is a Anjem Choudary kind of
supporter and who's been doing tech fear
this guy's been doing tap dia both of
them are the same in knowledge they have
a deficiency of it they're not trained
to do what they they claim to be able to
do which is to proclaim tip the antic
field on the people and they would never
show themselves in public and debate any
air or anybody who opposes them come
forward if you really believe in what
you believe in and will have a plan
challenge that's the first thing in the
video because the Quran says well look
at the s of not analytically for how
many more Decker we have surely made the
Quran easy for remembrance and recital
and so on so who's gonna be the one to
do it so if you can't even start with
that then how can you be talking about
these bigger things your dour traitor
and you're jealous of you're probably
jealous of all those people you've been
refuting including Zakir Naik you've
been refuting for so many years that you
can never be half the man he is
yeah you can't and you know it so this
is the reality situation there needs to
be people that are look plan if someone
slaps you slap them back intellectually
I don't believe in this whole thing I'll
just leave them ignore them yeah we've
got a big platform but once in a while
for an intellectual missile which will
make them shiver and quake in their
boots and scurry out of desperation and
that's what I say it is my is my message
to two people that look if you're really
interested in knowing Islam go to the
sources
yes you can follow in fib we can follow
on the deduced prudential schools of law
or effect of law like the humbly Malachy
a sheriff i Hanafy these are established
but in terms of creat you have to do
your own homework don't rely upon some
guy who's dropped out of university or
been failed three or four times a
university and the other one has got
credentials in a completely different
field and the third one who's who can't
recite the Quran properly these are your
figureheads these are your figureheads
and that's why the most susceptible
people to this kind of manipulation
intellectual manipulation are those who
are most weak in knowledge . they might
when they may come and appear to be two
or three people yeah may come out of
jail they come out of jail and they
needed a job and they rely on the
handouts of those guys that might have a
little bit more knowledge and might
support them but that's a different
thing so at the end of the day while
when i say to you is be careful and
follow the prophets advice as for those
two projects us as muslims as our these
fringe groups ante normative practices
yeah they need to be dealt with we need
to show the non-muslims as well the
community wider community that we're
dealing with those individuals yeah who
who are aligning the religion of Islam
and are posing a great barrier to entry
at the ridge of Islam and causing grave
doubts within the Muslim Ummah for our
youth so this is the reasoning why we
should be dealing with those individuals
and be warned against those individuals
and they are traitors and they should be
written down there are dour traitors
they're engaged in treachery and they
should be treated as such they should be
treated as such and I will leave in the
description box a video which I recently
done exposing one of them for actually
committing this one who says that he has
to believe in geo centricity yeah I we
find something of him where he's he's
saying about prophet Sulayman that he he
could he done magic
the Jews we see that magic became part
and parcel of their religion and when
they wrote the Talmud and they you know
and also because the Jews were captive
held captive by one of the kings of
Babylon in the year 600 so this king he
was called Nebuchadnezzar and he went to
Jerusalem he conquered the Jews he took
them back to Babylon and when the Jews
were in Babylon on top of the magic they
ran from Solomon on top of the magic we
learned from cinema upon the light and
magic needed magic black magic which is
covered to say this it's comfort to say
that but he's saying that about Solomon
Ali can you imagine so we're dealing
with them in the same way they try and
deal with us and this is the only way to
get these guys to quieten down and to
get their photos you realize that these
guys are fallible
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi or what
occurs